حال اهل هذه المدينه ان بها من الامان ما
يجعلها قبله للناجين من رصاص الحرب
والباحثين عن الحياه
ودمدني التي تبعد حوالي 180 كيلومترا
جنوبي الخرطوم فتحت البيوت فيها وكذلك
المدارس والمراكز لاستقبال كل من اتخذها
مقصدا للنجاه من هذه الاسر
والفري من الاحداث الخرطوم
قصدوا ولايه الجزيره بشكل اساسي
والانثى الجزيره
تستضيف اعداد كبيره جدا
في مراكز ايواء هناك حوالي 23 الى 24 مركز
تتوزع هذه المراكز بمدينه المدني وحالته
الميدان الكبرى وكذلك محليه شرق الجزيره
في مدينه رفاعه وكذلك في محلات الحصاحيصه
وكذلك محلات الكاملين
هنا في مدرسه المكنمر بمدينه ودمدني التي
تحولت الى مركز لاواء الناجين من رصاص
الحرب اجتهد الشابان مجتبى عبد الواحد
ومحمد عوض وتفرغ لتيسير مستلزمات الايواء
من ماكل ومشرب وتسكين لاكثر من
139 شخصا اغلبهم من الاطفال والنساء
فوفرنا دور بتاعه ايواء في البدايه كان
عددها ثلاثه مراكز يستضفنا العدد وصل لحد
312 فردي في البدايه
والحمد لله قدرنا نوفر لهم الاعاشه والسكن
والرعايه الطبيه حتى الرعايه النفسيه
نفسها
ثم ان القصص التي استمعنا اليها هنا جراء
الحرب والمشاهدات التي وقفنا عليها كثيره
بان تؤسس لمعنى ان اليقين من اوجب متطلبات
الحياه عند الازمات والملمات والله اعزي
علينا مبسوطين الحمد لله والشكر يا رب
العالمين
استقبلونا وفرهونا فرهوا ايالنا
الحمد لله يعني ما مخلي لنا شيء والله
يعني هم بيجوا زي اهلنا وقفوا معانا والله
بجد ما خلونا والله المركز واحد من حوالي
ثلاثه وعشرين مركزا بالولايه تعمل في
اتساق تام للوقوف مع القادمين الى الولايه
والباحثين عن معادله الامني في زمن الحرب
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب استقبلت هذه الولايه
اعدادا كبيره من الفارينه من الحرب
واستطاعت المجهودات الشعبيه من استيعاب
هذه التدفقات البشريه الكبيره اما المكان
هنا فرحابه الناس تنسيهم الام المصائب
محمد عثمان العربيه من ولايه الجزيره
مدينه ود مدني لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات